hey there it's Ben Shapiro host of the
Ben Shapiro show I just want to start by
saying thank you to all the responsibly
armed Americans out there despite what
the media are saying about you yes you
are making America safer so I want to
quickly touch on an organization that's
a great resource for the gun owners out
there the United States concealed-carry
Association I'm personally a member of
the US ECA and there's a pretty good
reason why they're the fastest growing
community of responsible gun owners in
the country for starters they've got
great education training and legal and
financial protection for members but
more to the point they actually care
about your inalienable right to
self-defense and they're out there doing
something to protect it our founding
fathers knew that all of us had an
inalienable right to self-defense and
that our right to self-defense extended
to our defense of Liberty that's why
they placed so much focus on ensuring
that individual citizens were protected
from government overreach but now the
left says you don't need your guns your
guns are a threat to innocent people we
should trust the government to protect
us from criminals and most of all we
should trust the government itself
we shouldn't it's not about what guns
you need it's about what you have right
to bear your guns aren't a threat to
law-abiding people they're your
protection against those who don't abide
by the law and a government deserving of
your trust wouldn't seek to disarm you
in the first place so I'll say it again
for all your responsible gun owners out
there thanks for making America safer
sorry you don't hear that more often you
deserve more support not a tax on your
Second Amendment rights which is why I
have a member of the u.s. ECA I'm like
the television pundits and politicians
the u.s. ECA is actually doing something
that'll make people safer so if you are
not a US ECA member yet look into it
they've got a lot to offer and they're
really great group of people